bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous
parlez nous un peu de cette rencontre
hier entre jean yves le drian et le
premier ministre libanais à l'hypothèse
la réflexion du premier ministre
libanais hassan diab que vous venez
d'évoquer est pour le moins qu'on puisse
dire de déplacés d'ailleurs je pense
bien que je pense que le tweet au cours
duquel il a il a fait cette réflexion a
été retiré elles étaient placés parce
que il était évident que le ministre un
gendre jean yves le drian n'avait pas
apporté une aide là n'est pas annoncé
une aide au gouvernement libanais parce
que ça fait depuis peut-être plus de
deux ans que la france et la communauté
internationale demande exhorte les
dirigeants libanais à mettre en place
des réformes des réformes fondamentales
pour redresser l'économie et la
communauté internationale et la france
ont bien précisé au cours des deux
dernières années surtout depuis la
conférence de soutien à l'économie
libanaise qui s'est tenu à paris en
avril 2018
donc la france a bien souligné que tant
que les réformes ne sont pas mises en
place la communauté internationale la
france et le fmi ne pouvait pas
prétendre liban donc le ministre le chef
du quai d'orsay a il été et c'était
qu'on utilisait réaffirmé cette position
coup deux sets de 7 de sa visite à
beyrouth
donc la réflexion de hassan diab est
pour le moins qu'on puisse dire
surprenante parce que tout le monde
savait que le chef du quai d'orsay aller
réaffirmé avec fox avec fermeté la
position de la communauté internationale
derrière monsieur le drian a aussi mis
l'accent sur cette position
au cours d'un débat au sénat français
lorsqu'il a lancé cette fameuse phrase
qui a fait beaucoup de bruit au liban
aidez nous à qui s'adresser aux
dirigeants libanais monsieur le drian a
lancé en réponse à une question d'un
député français et l'avancé aux
dirigeants libanais et de nous
pour qu'on puisse vous aider donc ça
s'est résumé un peu le thème de la
visite de monsieur le drian un bébé
cette visite à cette visite elle a eu
lieu en fin de semaine dernière puisque
jean yves le drian a quitté le liban
beyrouth ont tout à vendredi dernier
c'était hier c'est moi qui ait été
commis alors juste pour revenir sur
l'aide de la france au liban comment la
france perd soit elle justement la crise
économique que traverse actuellement le
pays
alors ici il faut se placer sur un
double blanc d'abord le ministre
français a annoncé une aide aux écoles
aux écoles libanaises et ça c'est un
point fondamental est très important
évidemment ça ne ça ne règle pas les
problèmes économiques du liban mais au
niveau des libanais au niveau de la
société libanaise
il a annoncé une aide de 15 millions
d'euros aux écoles libanaises
conventionnés c'est à dire des écoles
libanaises qui suivent le programme
français al aqsa dans le contexte de la
crise économique c'est une aide
fondamentale est très importante qui a
été très apprécié au niveau de la
société du bénin sacyr au niveau privé
pas au niveau de l'économie libanaise
il y à des réformes qui sont requises
depuis deux et trois ans pour mettre un
terme au gaspillage au niveau des fêtes
des dépenses publiques et pour vous
mettre un terme un peu malade
dilapidation des fonds publics
il ya des réformes qui sont requises au
niveau du secteur de l'électricité qui
coûtent au trésor non moins de deux
milliards de dollars par an de
subventions qui sont totalement inutiles
et qu'ils ne peuvent être économisés que
si le gouvernement met en place met en
place une série de réformes dans le
secteur de l'électricité
la france et le fmi la communauté
internationale
insiste beaucoup sur ce point sur la
réforme au niveau du secteur électricité
l'administration publique libanaise et
une administration qui est que kiki qui
est super gonflé et kiki qui coûtent au
trésor aussi des milliards de dollars
par an je le disais tout à l'heure la
population qui est en première ligne
finalement il ya ce constat de l'eau
angie save the children aussi au liban
plus d'un demi million d'enfants en
lutte pour leur survie dans un pays donc
on l'expliquait en plein naufrage
économique
comment l'expliquer il y à l'économie
libanaise l'économie libanaise a subi un
choc depuis près d'un an en raison de
l'augmentation de du déficit public en
raison de l'augmentation de la dette de
la dette publique qui a eu pour effet de
provoquer un effondrement de la de la
livre libanaise dans sa super recul à
tous les niveaux de la vie quotidienne
des libanais que ce soit au niveau du
pouvoir d'achat d'abord et même au
niveau 1 au niveau des salaires le taux
de change entre le dollar et la livre
libanaise la livre du manège a perdu
plus de 80% de sa valeur à nos ça se
répercute sur le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages et ça se répercute évidemment à
tous les niveaux de la société libanaise
essentiellement donc au niveau des
écoles comme je le disais tout à l'heure
d'où le fait les répercussions au niveau
des enfants au niveau scolaire au niveau
universitaire à tous les niveaux de la
vie quotidienne des ménages iban et
justement ce que monsieur le drian a
réaffirmé au liban ce que pour redresser
l'économie libanaise pour pour améliorer
de nouveau le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages libanais il ya des réformes
structurelles qui doivent être mises en
place et la communauté internationale
les pays arabes ne cesse de l'affirmer
ne pourrait il ne pourrait y avoir des
aides du fmi au liban que si ces
réformes sont mises en place
donc monsieur le drian a réaffirmé cette
position d'une façon ferme et ça ça se
répercute donc comme je le disais au
niveau du pouvoir d'achat des libanais
est-ce que très rapidement on va
conclure est ce que les dirigeants
libanais en prennent justement la mesure
est ce qu'ils vont faire mettre en place
justement ces réformes
là il ne cesse de l'affirmer
publiquement mais pratiquement jusqu'à
maintenant on n'a rien vu de concret est
ce que monsieur le drian a dit c'est
très joli le premier ministre a
réaffirmé à monsieur le devenir que le
gouvernement était déterminé à mettre en
place sa grille phone mais il faut
encore faut-il que concrètement qu on
puisse voir que s'ils fermenté mis en
place or jusqu'à présent on n'a rien vu
encore sur seclin et c'est là leur tout
le problème
il faut que concrètement et non pas sur
le papier parce qu'il ya des conditions
qui ont été formés il ya des réunions
qui sont tenus pour étudier les mettre
en place sa grille fort mais encore
faut-il que concrètement sur le terrain
qu'elle soit vraiment concrétisé pas des
mesures au niveau législatif et au
niveau exécutif ce qui n'a pas encore eu
lieu
merci à vous à michel être mais je
rappelle que vous êtes co rédacteur en
chef et directeur responsable de journal
lorient à le jour merci à vous